The first priority is to prevent contact with the city.It
takes about an hour to reach the
target.Therefore, we will set up a final line of defense and annihilate the giant dragon before it passes through.If we
cannot annihilate
it, then Blantation  In order to
defend itself, it uses the fuel in its body to repeatedly
explode.If it receives a month after the attack, there should be a chance
to finish it off.Do you mean leaving Goro to death?
This operation will start 15 minutes after the current time
Everyone prepares for the sortie
[Music]
Hana
Before that, let me talk to you.
When I said what I could do, I
realized that it was good for the time being
.
I'll help you,
so you lose
Strawberry
Are you
crying?  Around
[music]
I can afford to be alone
b 2